hey everyone how's it going welcome back
and hope you are well today I have a
very special two-part video series where
I have my friend Kelsey on the channel
to talk about internships Kelsey would
you like to introduce yourself
sure I'm Kelsey I make a channel called
Kelsey makes things where I make things
with code and also make videos of my
life College as a new grad soon and yeah
check it out if you want yeah there's a
link in the description box down below
so please check that out so the first
part of this video will be talking about
why internships are important especially
for those of you who are maybe just
stepping into college or try and get
your first internship we want to talk
about the real value of it like why
should we have internships specifically
we're going to cover what can you learn
in an internship a little bit about our
personal experiences in an internship
and then also if you don't get an
internship what are some things that you
could do during the summer or the winter
or whenever to hone your skills and to
just become the next best version of you
so the very first thing we're going to
talk about is how software internships
can really teach you a lot about
yourself so oftentimes internships are
talked about as waste to gain experience
and skills in the industry but really we
think that it's a really great way to
learn about what specifically you want
at the end of the day the tech industry
is so wide and there's so many different
things that you can do and internships
are a great way to kind of just like
sample different things and just see how
they feel yeah so an internship at base
level this is a great opportunity to
learn about life at the specific company
that you're interning at even more than
that you can figure out whether software
engineering is right for you
maybe you want to go into another
related job in tech maybe something like
product management data science etc etc
there's so many possibilities you can
even learn about whether you want to be
in tech at all you might find that you
love tech and you want to stay in this
industry forever or you might find out
that this is maybe not what you want to
be doing right now and that's totally
fine too yeah it's totally okay this
isn't necessarily meant to discourage
you it's just like not everyone wants to
be like an artist not everyone wants to
like a builder and that's okay at the
end of the day like you don't really
know until you try and be able to sample
things and really just being in there as
a software engineer through a three
month or six month long internship can
tell you like hey do you actually enjoy
doing this so a question that I often
get on this channel is around what part
of the tech industry do you want to get
into around sectors and domain knowledge
as well as like nonprofits for-profits
enterprises just because do a product
there's so many things you could
probably work on like the Tesla app -
like car things like there's just the
limits are endless and sometimes it can
be kind of decision paralysis but
internships are a great way to figure
that out as well some other things that
you can also find out at an internship
is what kind of technical problems are
you interested in tackling there's so
many different technical fields within
tech there are there's security infra
back-end front-end data etc so many
again you could have decision paralysis
from something like this but at least
from an internship you'll get a feel for
whether you liked the technical problems
you were solving or whether you did it
you can also learn about what size of
company that you're interested in
whether the size of the company that
you're interning at suits you and
whether you want to be there long term
for me that was a huge huge thing that I
learned during my internships I was
lucky enough to intern at companies that
had tens of people - hundreds of people
- tens of thousands of people those are
the companies that I had a chance to see
and it had a huge impact on where I saw
myself in the future
and of course we've just presented a
bunch of questions that you can kind of
get the answer a little bit - at your
internships but during internships you
can also find out which ones of these
questions that you actually care about
do you care about the size as much do
you care about the technical problems as
much do you care about the domain these
things all have varying impacts on
people and how happy they are with their
jobs so at an internship you can
definitely get a feel for that all of
those things all these factors can
really impact whether you like the
or not they're all really like small
minut differences that like you can just
kind of read stats on but they are going
to really change how you view your work
and what brings you fulfillment and
that's kind of at the end of the day
when you're looking for an internship
you're looking for that piece that feels
like something that you would be really
interested in and excited to continue
working on so so far we've talked about
how there's just so many factors that go
into an internship that help you stamp
out all the different experiences out
there in tech so now we want to talk
about our own experiences also what are
some of the things that we think are
really underrated that we can pull out
from and learn from an internship so I
think internships are super effective in
teaching you how to adult I'm still
getting there myself but the
relationships that you build an
internship are similar I mean pretty
much the same as the relationships you
would be building at a full-time job
there's so many things to learn there
around like how do you communicate with
other people on your team how do you
communicate when doing work together how
do you ask for help how do you build
relationships and Trust with other
people that you're working with these
are skills that are not really taught in
college or really anywhere else and
these are some of the really important
skills that will start your career on
the first step because a lot of your
career is determined by who you know and
what kinds of relationships you have and
how you move through this industry
something underrated that I learned at
some of my internships was that your
value is not purely technical you
learned so much about culture at these
companies especially if it's a small
company people will love for you to take
initiative you're not only experiencing
the culture of these companies you can
also help define it yeah and companies
value so much of this Russia perspective
that interns and early career people as
well as just new hires have because they
haven't worked there they're not that
familiar with the product and then
bringing in their own perspective is
awesome it's another way to improve
themselves and companies are really
looking for that
sidenote the buzzing is from
construction and we're working through
it y'all so another really cool thing
that you can learn in internships is
learning what your learning style is
throughout middle school high school
college whatever your education has been
there usually is kind of late learning
style that may have been pushed on to
you but in internships and in jobs you
can kind of explore how you learn best
is not your meeting is that you're
working on it with somebody else is that
through just like trying it out and
seeing what happens it kind of serves as
almost like a playground for you to just
get your feet wet try out things make
mistakes
those are super highly encouraged and
it's a great way to get to know yourself
like we talked about before through
internships and jobs I learned that I'm
like terrible at learning from like a
lecture style or just reading I'm really
good at learning in a very like engaged
environment but when I got to an
internship learning that hey I can
program with somebody and solve
something together and that's how I can
learn a concept my learning skyrocketed
and it really unlocked a part of me and
it made me realize like oh this is the
key this is how I learned everything
else in life which is so valuable that's
a really rare opportunity to do that and
internships are great testbeds to do
that because you're encouraged to learn
things you're encouraged to make
mistakes you're encouraged to interact
just so many people out there another
thing we wanted to mention is that
internships are totally two-sided you
should try to demonstrate the value that
you can bring the company and this will
relate to whether you get an offer
letter or not you know practical things
like that but it's also a way for the
company to demonstrate what value it can
bring for you so your mentor or your
manager will probably be providing you
feedback and I think it's a rare
opportunity like as a college student or
someone who's coming into tech to hear
from someone else what they think you
could be doing better it's kind of like
bringing someone into your own career
journey and having them help you which
is invaluable because you're obviously
going to have blind spots there's things
that you don't know and getting that
insight from other people through a
working environment is just so great
yeah and you especially if you're
a school with bigger classes this can be
the kind of one-on-one feedback that you
need to improve your skills so hopefully
by now we've like sold you on how
important internships are and also how
valuable they can be but also you might
not get one and that's also totally ok
it is very competitive and it will just
get more competitive and also if you're
maybe only a year's worth of school out
then it's likely that the internships
will go to second in third years but we
want to also just talk about like what
if you don't get one what can you do is
it okay that you don't get an internship
every summer what do you think healthy
yeah I have heard so much about people
getting internships before their
freshman in college sometimes it's
overwhelming to hear about everybody
else's success story but you can learn
so much from environments that are not
traditional Tech internships as well of
course but sometimes this is not
mentioned internships are not everything
there's so many ways to learn the same
skills and same values that we just
talked about there's so many other ways
so just because you didn't get an
initiative doesn't mean that you're a
failure and that you're not supposed to
be here there are so many other ways to
do it and initiatives just happen to be
a really great testbed for it some
things that you can be doing if you
didn't get an internship but you still
want to have like a productive summer
you can apply for fellowships or
research opportunities that are not in
the tech industry you can teach you can
take up a different summer job you can
take online classes or even in-person
classes you can read you can kind of get
an education on your own or you could
even work on a personal project and who
knows where this could take you one
summer where I didn't get in internships
I worked on a pet project of Mines I had
wanted to build since high school it was
like a game so I learned a lot about
react native just like random things and
of course just became more familiar with
programming so this was super super
helpful to me and in fact if I had
gotten an internship that year I think I
just would have been a totally different
person today
because that challenged me to think
outside the box to pursue something that
wasn't really conventional but
ultimately it was super super rewarding
to me yeah because at the end of the day
the way that we've talked about the
value of internships is that you get to
know yourself really well and so if you
do that through personal projects your
hobbies like you said those are also
really great ways especially if you're
in college like this just this is just
the best time to get to know who you
really are what excites you what doesn't
excite you and you can do this without
an internship especially if you're maybe
in your first or second year of college
yes there is definitely an emphasis on
kind of the output that you've created
and what that output is but even more
valuable than die is figuring out who
you are because that sets you up for
your third and fourth years where you
are going to be applying to full-time
jobs and internships and you're just
going to know what you want and you're
going to be working towards that
throughout the school year and that is
just a very like self-aware way of going
through it but those are really
important lessons that and you take
along with you throughout your entire
life and I think summers are a great
time to do that because there's no so
much yeah no classes there's no summer
vacation we can start working in the car
sometimes so taking this time and just
slowing down is also totally perfectly
right so to wrap up basically
internships are all about learning about
who you are it's not the end LVL if you
don't have an internship and really it's
just what can you get from an internship
for yourself that's the really important
part and hopefully this stuff that we've
talked about today will be really
helpful for you to think about as you
look through internships as you apply to
internships and also as you go through
them as well so I hope you liked this
video we made another one about how to
get a software engineering internship we
provide all of our insights and our
experiences in that video so definitely
check that out that'll also be in the
description box down below and give us
thumbs up and please subscribe and also
go check out Kelsey's Channel
we'll also be in the description box
down below so thanks for being on the
channel thank you in the next video bye